it's a new year and it's time to kick
things into high gear with a new
character list
I just realized to my shock that the
channels featured uses of Fire and Ice
but we haven't taken a look at another
common element yep you heard right for
being such a common power we've yet to
make a list of the top uses of such
ability that is until today now I
present to you the top 10 users of
electricity in anime make sure to hang
tight and brace yourself for one hell of
an electrifying list
I want to start slow but that isn't the
style for our first entrant Gil Thunder
proudly holding the rank of diamond this
holy night has the power to generate and
manipulate lighting masterful use of his
abilities allows him to fight with speed
and power making him a tough opponent
for those foolish enough to challenge
him despite his stoic front Gil Thunder
hides a dark and troubled past without
spoilers I'll just say that he's had one
of the more tragic backstories in the
series overall Gil thunders one cool
character with a nifty ability and some
hidden depths a nice choice to set the
tone for the rest of the list
the sentences sure made a name for
himself in the past year has a need if
first impressions are anything to go by
he seemed like a bumbling sidekick good
for a fair share of laughs unsuccessful
advances on girls and a moment of glory
only to be overshadowed immediately
however this board of energy actually
had the most badass moments in Demon
Slayer with not one but two amazing
performances in the anime Xena Tzu
deserves a mention as a member of this
top lightning users Club he may not have
as many wins in the back as our hero nor
have gimmicky powers like the moons and
the pillars but watchings in its who go
to work on demons is a treat with a
movie looming and most likely a second
season on its way
fans will be pleased to see more of them
itsu as we approach them
looks like we have a black clover
representative for our lucky 7 a magic
knight and a member of the black balls
and luck takes pride in his lightning
magic though his tactics remain lacking
then again with powers are strongest his
attacking recklessly would undoubtedly
be your first choice in solving things I
think what makes Luck unique is his
creation magic he uses this form of
magic to shape objects from lightning he
can clad himself with lightning to
enhance his fighting skills - so when it
comes to it he's pretty awesome when he
stops and thinks for all his reckless
attacking luck has a knack for being a
good analyzer in black clovers run as an
anime luck shown to be more than a
capable fighter getting his fair share
of awesome moments and wins
here's someone haven't heard about in a
while I almost forgot about darker than
black but how can I forget one of the
most badass electric users in the
mid-late 2000s taking control of quantum
physics in the form of electricity pay
showed anime fans from over a decade ago
how it's done
ever thought electric based powers would
mean some sort of reality warping even
after losing use electricity based
superpowers
pay still kicks serious ass among the
black wearing brooding heroes of action
anime I think the hey is one of the most
badass ones out there want to see more
of him in action then watch darker than
black it's an underrated show that has
somewhat been forgotten
badass protagonists aside you should
watch it for its nice themes in general
atmosphere
I think Americans a nice dusting how
much gonzo yes sir berry berries finally
made it to the list
the third among the level five Esper's
Misaka Mikoto is primarily known for one
thing has signature railgun by
manipulating energy she's able to turn
something as harmless as a coin into a
dreaded beam of death simple but
effective such as the power of science
moussaka can also generate magnetic
fields and cause blackouts with wild
strikes of lightning her place among the
top
espers of Academy cities definitely not
for show as seen in numerous seasons of
index and railgun if only this ace of
Academy City had such good luck and
standing in the field of romance catch
her latest adventures with her friends
in the upcoming railgun tea
[Music]
[Music]
nissim burrito
the Lord of Skype here isn't called God
for nothing that nicknames also gone to
his head it seems being called God's
made him think that he's an actual God
and that everyone else is just a mortal
beneath him that's right this is a
character with a god complex unlike
anything I've seen in a while
to make matters worse it appears that
vaporizing of floating islands just one
of those casual God things he can just
do as he pleases in addition to control
over lightning NL also serves as a
character who first demonstrates a
specific kind of hockey if Luffy wasn't
at an advantage due to the properties of
rubber
who knows how their fights and
subsequently the sky Pia Ark would have
turned out
starting off our top three is everyone's
favorite edge Lord ninja Sasuke
besides Kanye bündchen & Rasengan
Chidori in my opinion is one of the
Naruto series iconic abilities and who
better to feature on the list than the
master of it Sasuke wait isn't the
creator of Chidori a different person to
be frank I had a short debate with
myself whether to feature Sasuke Reich
are gay or Kakashi here by went with
Sasuke because he plays a bigger role in
the story and has far more impressive
performances in the series Plus this is
the guy who's taken Chidori further by
integrating it with various techniques
creating brand new evolutions to the
original attack in the world of Naruto
few can match Sasuke especially in a
state at the end of the series and this
fact makes an epic final showdown with
the titular character well worth the
wait
[Music]
I'm about you but lightning might not be
the first thing that comes to mind when
one takes a quick look at kilowatt for a
first impression however this is one
dangerous assassin you don't want to
mess with armed with the nen ability to
generate electricity kilowatts one of
the most impressive characters in hunter
hunter as if coming from a family of
assassins isn't enough kilowatt takes
this ability of generating electricity
to the next level soon enough he gains
the ability to apply it to his own body
further enhancing his already excellent
physical capabilities personally a place
to kill away here because though his
electric powers aren't as flashy as
everyone else's you can't see such a
creative use of electric powers in
conjunction with physical prowess and
speed coming from a well-written key
character who stars in one of the best
Shonen anime there is wouldn't it
surprise you if Kilowog were to be
absent instead topping our list is none
other than the legendary king of the
seven seas
it's Sinbad
[Music]
for those who've watched Maggie let me
ask you a serious question
what can Sinbad not do the only is he
the undisputed leader of the seven seas
Alliance he also has access to the most
Jin's of all the characters in the show
he's never lost the fight it has the
unique skill of accessing both light and
dark side abilities he's truly a special
singularity with his versatility and of
course his preferred gene for battle the
Lightning shooting ball it's telling
when at the end of the kingdom of magic
it's his appearance and lightning bolt
elicited a reaction from the villain
something that not even almost all of
the gin users of the Co empire together
managed to do trust me go and read the
manga it gets way crazier over there and
you'd have to see endgame Sinbad to
believe it it's insane how powerful he
becomes I wouldn't want to spoil it for
you but I guess you should go and read
the rest of marki since the new seasons
probably not gonna happen anytime soon
[Music]
have you experienced these characters
electrifying your screens before if not
you better start watching their shows
for more content like this better hit
that like and subscribe button don't
forget to let your thoughts be heard
through the comments section as well who
knows maybe some of your suggestions
will be made into a list in the future
I'll see you next time on mini tube
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]